luca leute lieben freunde ich wünsche
euch einen guten rutsch ins neue jahr
wie es bereits im titel seht geht das
heutige video um eine woche im leben von
luca also von mir allerdings zeige ich
euch jetzt nicht eine woche hier in
hamburg wie ich hier lebe und so weiter
und so fort sondern wir reagieren auf
ein video was ich über eine woche in
meinem leben von mir gemacht haben tun
hat vom 22 juni 2014 also auf ein video
was sechs jahre her ist
ich hatte das ja so mega gefallen wie
ich mir meinen ersten block angeschaut
habe vorher dachte ich wir schauen uns
jetzt mal wieder ein altes video an
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt schon
kein bock mehr da wird herzlich
alter
der standard stuhl mit den sachen bei
denen man nicht weiß wo sie hinkommen
ist natürlich auch wieder mit dabei
david herzlich willkommen meine lieben
freunde zum heutigen kontakt wo ich euch
machen konnte
da habe ich sonntag immer als kozak
betitelt und da ein remake video gemacht
eine woche beginnt mit montag also es
war war ich am montag den ganzen tag in
der thier-galerie dortmund mit einer
freundin mit einer freundin und dabei
auch crooner regeln geachtet
ich hatte einfach nicht mehr freuen wird
ein iphone das ist ein bisschen der 42
der app dies das ab
[Musik]
ich denke und alles was ihnen gefällt
das seht ihr jetzt aber man sich nun
über diese sonnenbrille auf es scheint
ja augenscheinlich nicht die sonne habe
ich die musik vom haus nicht ausmachen
[Musik]
am dienstag musste ich um sieben uhr
morgens aufstehen weil ich blut und urin
bei seinem arzt abgeben musste warum
liegen da eigentlich hanteln der
gaszähler wenn ich damit jemals sport
gemacht habe da habe ich auch etwas
gefühlt dass edf
[Musik]
ein fahrrad
und diese schuhe ich das jetzt gerade im
autos ist seit vier wochen man schnupfen
und verkehr zwischen den ärzten wann ich
gräser und wollen und milben allergie
hat und habe ich auch noch irgendwie die
voll
jahreszeit wurde es am einfachsten ist
er ja das ist so schlimm
über diese zeit so märz april mai juni
vor
da kann ich auch gar nicht atmen decker
joggen
was ist denn mit mir los ist nicht
gedacht dass die sonne so schön
untergehen
ich immer weg
aber ganz schön krass ja da sieht man
dass so ein bisschen die sonne halten
wir fest wenn man sich mit der
taschenlampe vom handy ins gesicht
leuchtet blendete
und an einer stelle habe ich dann auch
mal die sonne gezeigt keine ahnung wo
luca vor sechs jahren hier der sonne
gesehen hat ich muss halt irgendwas
machen deswegen bin ich nach draußen
gegangen bin joggen gegangen
wo es heißt joggen nicht joggen
halter
und ich weder stylen
noch kann ich reden
alles sachen die ich jetzt immer noch
nicht kann ich fahrer nachts autos
expandieren für eine scheiße aber das
seht ihr alles jetzt
[Musik]
du bist bei der männer waren am
donnerstag
warum ich weiß nicht irgendwelches
gestern gemacht das hat was auch schöner
finde man halt das hat was
das ist cool wenn man so spät abends
sorgen gehen wer das ist eigentlich
alles andere als gut wenn sie die
sondern schon so oft weg ist es gerade
10 uhr und ich habe karten kleinen igel
getroffen
[Musik]
ich habe nie getroffen habe den
paddington genannt du hast getroffen und
bedingung genannt
ich habe mich wirklich gar nichts mehr
hier und finde ich ist ein sehr schöner
name
so würde ich zwar nicht mein kind nennen
aber untersagt
[Musik]
ich glaube ich mit dem verwandt sein
paar denken ja jedenfalls hier seht ihr
wie der igel erhaltet ihr auf instagram
folgen so langsam kann das schon früher
gesehen
da nur sehr sehr schöne aufnahme hier
gerade von einer qualität wie das war
mir schon immer sehr wichtig ja alle die
mir auf instagram folgen at laser luca
die sehen so was für ihr könnt ihr dann
auch die hammer geil ich meine silvester
gestern gefeiert habe
schon krass ich hab seit letztem jahr
keine neuen videos mehr hoch
[Musik]
ach nee
das war die planung
für unsere london reise was ja dann mein
erster richtiger block war am samstag
ist eine menge passiert uns war am
samstag bin ich morgens erst nach köln
gefahren haben frühstück dumont piano
und dann sind wir weiter gefahren zum
nürburgring
zum wasser
nürburgring nach hamburg haben wir viel
zu schön so
sechs jahren habe ich schon gesagt haben
wir es aus wenn köln beste start aber
hamburg ist aus sicht und genauso
sie ist jetzt auch noch in hamburg ist
die schönste stadt in ganz deutschland
finde ich aber köln ist die
entspannteste stadt in ganz deutschland
so da war es auch schon tee getrunken
ich bin mir nie fremd gegangen
dieses video
beschreibt
den ganzen kanal
ich verspreche mich die ganze zeit ich
es pizza
ich trinke tee
ich liebe köln und hamburg und ich bin
hässlich moment da kam noch ein kleiner
nach knipser vor die nase natürlich die
nase ja so viele menschen da sind schon
geil als signal der unglaublich ist
schon brutal wieder ein wenig uns
entwickelt
die erste kurve am nürburgring auf sogar
die schikane naja was passiert jetzt
sage ich noch im video ich bin im 24
stundenlauf euro
[Musik]
nicht nur ein paar mehr und dann würde
ich auch sagen was das von einer woche
in meinem leben ist so kann es ruhig
sein jetzt ja wenn ich dem ganzen jetzt
sowieso eine schul bewertung geben
müsste wäre es glaube ich 06 - wenn euch
allerdings meine reaktion auf dieses
sechs jahre alte video von mir gefallen
hat das kann einen daumen hoch
untermieter abonniert main kanal noch
keiner der lupo seit und schreiber und
in die kommentare seit wann überhaupt
schon abonnent weit sei
[Musik]